hey this is presh to Walker someone
posted this question online with the
request how to solve this crazy hard
question
the roots of 2x squared minus X Plus K
is equal to zero our sine Theta and
cosine Theta what is the value of K
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
I will present two equivalent ways to
solve the problem the first uses
brahmagupta's quadratic formula
a general quadratic equation has a form
ax squared plus BX plus C is equal to
zero one root is X is equal to the
opposite of B plus the square root of B
squared minus 4AC all over 2A and the
other root will be the opposite of B
minus the square root of B squared minus
4AC all over 2A
in this particular quadratic equation a
is equal to 2 B is equal to negative one
and C is equal to K
so we just substitute into the formula
so we get that one root is equal to one
plus the square root of one minus eight
K that's all over four and the other
root is one minus the square root of one
minus eight K all over four
so where do we go from here
well the roots have square roots so
usually when we have square roots we
want to eliminate them by squaring the
term somehow and we know the roots are
equal to sine Theta and cosine Theta so
we think about formulas with sine Theta
and cosine Theta that are squared and of
course we want to use sine squared theta
plus cosine squared theta is equal to
one
so we will sum up the squares of these
roots that'll be equal to one
so we Square One root add it to the
square of the other and we know that's
equal to one so All That Remains is to
solve this equation so let's work it out
squaring the first term we get one plus
two times the square root of one minus
eight K plus one minus eight K all over
16. then we add the second term which is
one minus two root one minus eight K
plus one minus 8K all over 16 and this
is all equal to one
now we have some cancellations
the radical terms will cancel out
because we have plus 2 times the radical
and minus two times the radical
so we cancel these and then we just
group like terms
so this all works out to be 4 minus 16k
all over the same denominator 16 is
equal to 1.
we multiply both sides by 16 so we have
4 minus 16k is equal to 16.
now we subtract 4 from both sides so
negative 16k is equal to 12 and this
means that K is equal to negative 12
over 16 which is equal to negative 3
over 4 which equals negative 0.75 and
that's one way to get the answer
now I want to go over another way you
could solve this problem you could use
the product and sum of roots formulas
so in a quadratic equation ax squared
plus BX plus C is equal to zero
the product of the two Roots will be C
over a and the sum of the two Roots will
be negative B over a
so we have a is equal to 2 B is equal to
negative 1 and C is equal to K so we
substitute in that the product of the
roots is equal to K over 2 and the sum
of the roots is equal to one over two
now we also know the roots are sine
Theta and cosine Theta
so sine Theta times cosine Theta is
equal to K over 2 and sine theta plus
cosine Theta is equal to 1 over 2. so
let's work from here
now what we'll do is we'll square the
second equation
so we need the square of sine theta plus
cosine Theta and that's equal to the
square of one-half which equals one over
four
so we have sine squared theta plus two
times sine Theta cosine theta plus
cosine squared theta is equal to one
over four now sine Square theta plus
and we know that sine Theta times cosine
Theta is equal to K over 2 so 2 times
that will be equal to K so this
simplifies to be 1 plus K is equal to
one over four and that means K is equal
to negative three over four which equals
negative
0.75 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]